that's one of the craziest things like
you'd be shocked how much your
relationship with your siblings improve
as you create
more distance like like sometimes
proximity is the problem yes you know
because we have daily stress and they're
there so they can
be our proverbial punching bag so we let
it on them but it's not healthy
it's toxic my relationship with my
mother improved tenfold the moment i
moved up
it was a little bit of a friction period
but after that like where we are now
compared to where i was then there was a
point then where i would
here's when you know you need to leave
if you talk
about your siblings the way you talk
about people you hate
yes that's when it's time to go yeah
like once you're starting to use
language
very like this man
like i hear people talk about their
minds they use the word don't get me
wrong there's some parents out there who
are just terrible people so
caveat that's maybe your situation but
oftentimes it's like in minor situations
like
man this is snagging me again i'm like
brah who talk about your who
oh [ __ ] goddamn
oh man it's rough out there if you and i
are constantly
in conflict you need to sort out
whatever you got in here that's making
you externalize that and if you're not
willing to do that for our relationship
to exist
then we need to cut that tie i imagine
because i can't fix
what you don't want to acknowledge yeah
if i don't want to change if it's a you
problem
you got to fix it again if it's an us
problem where
like we could work things out or it's a
misunderstanding
right some things can be just
misunderstandings right okay right let's
talk it out right
let's talk it out in order for this
never to to happen let's set boundaries
yeah but some people they don't listen
you always
you always argue over dumb dumb stuff
it's like when i moved out about terry's
house yeah my mom was like oh
okay i gotta admit the way i moved
bossaji my mom was like me your father
and uh your aunt were going on a cruise
on that date and that date
blah blah keep kept on reminding me and
the week before they leave
a couple of days before they leave like
okay we're going on a cruise
so yeah i'm like yeah when you're gonna
come back on your cruise i'm not gonna
be there
and she's like oh what activities do you
have no woman you don't understand
i'm not going to be there my bed's going
to be moved out
everything going to be go i'm out i'm
out and she was like oh my god it's like
boo boo we keep fighting
it's time for me to go i got an
opportunity to go
we keep fighting you know every time we
talk
it's a battle right and then after that
you ask dad to
tag team y'all he don't know what's
going on but he can't pick my side
like it's her bad i needs to go lady
and she was not really happy about it
yeah but
it was necessary at some point when you
gotta go you gotta go
even in relationships for me i'm not the
kind of i'm not the kind of
guy that's going to be in a couple where
she's going to be stuck to me
24 7. do do something
do some stuff yeah do you do you have
friends
keep some separation do you have friends
go chat with your friend i don't need to
chill with you
and your friend no go go watch you
little sometimes she was
she watches um she watched
show garbage shows i don't like those
shows and i'm like yo
do you it's entertaining to you do you
and she chats with a girl that
i'ma head out i'ma go on my bike i'm
gonna go you know and she's like yeah
cool
sometimes doing stuff separately is a
wonderful thing
you don't have to be stuck together all
7. yup oh yeah guess what
guess what rocks it's good to have
whenever you cherish that proximity it's
nice and everything and stuff but
sometimes
you know how many times my girl went on
trips without me
never [ __ ] because we don't let these
i don't like at some point i was
starting a new job i just started the
job
and she was like well i'm gonna go on i
was supposed we're supposed to go on
vacation i'm like
go go
go on vacation i can't go go don't don't
don't go go on vacay read books
wake up at five in the morning on your
vacation that you wanna
do do you live your life get some cuban
d
sure sure she would never
what happens in cuba stays in cuba
except herpes you bring that
back
oh yes you're gonna need it for that
therapy
i got an itch and then you start
scratching your neck that's perfect
you got some more than my craps
all right so yeah but that's pretty much
it sometimes you just gotta
yeah guys guys i'm telling you there's a
lot of people who need to be separated
from their family members not because
you know someone's sometimes you just
need a bit of distance
and you know staying at home is great to
save money and i recommend it to a lot
of people but if your environment is
toxic
don't sacrifice your mental health for
financial health
your brain matters your mental
well-being
matters i'll break matters
i'm serious like i know a lot of people
are staying home because it's to save
money and there's
and they're tolerating the circumstance
that are just pretty much unlivable
guys a lot of you need to spread your
wings and just bounce
you need to fly you're doing more hurt
on the long
long term by staying there and just
taking that in at some point you're
going to end up
because you're going to get up and end
up being hurt and what happens is you're
going to
be with something else in another
situation and you know
hurt people bleed on people that didn't
cut them
yes and that's whack you know you're
gonna end up
acting a certain way because you got
trauma for past
relationship whether it's with your girl
whether it's your parents or
your family members or whatever what not
you're going to end up bleeding that out
on somebody else and that's just whack
yep
also you know someone said well i don't
have the money get the money
get a job start saving bounce
well abba um my mom won't let me
make a decision for yourself you're a
grown-ass person if your parents are
still making all the decisions for you
after you've hit 18 you got a problem
at some point you have to be independent
enough to stand up for yourself and make
your own decisions
because your parents won't be around
forever and make your choices
and if they won't let you do a [ __ ]
move
do do a move do a move that like leave
when they're not looking right
if they're gonna light up your lit up
your phone and stuff like that
they can't they can't do so much one
thing that i've learned
from leaving my mom's house is i value
peace
my home is peaceful bills might be
stressful the world out there my boss
they might be stressful but when i get
back to my house
that is peace and serenity when i live
alone
and i don't hear nothing around me and i
get to control the noise factor
when somebody can't just barge into my
room and nag me for some
that's peace yeah you know you know
where mcgran's parents love to do that
so whether it's parents whether it's a
girlfriend whether it's a roommate
guys find yourself a living arrangement
that offers you peace
and you need that you need a space that
actually feels like
home if home is torture for you
that's not home you're just in a foreign
space
enemy territory my mom used to do that
the nagging white in the morning
goosebumps yo why it's nine in the
morning lady
yep i got goosebumps it's nine in the
morning lady why
you what happened you're so upset it's
like you're just
you're exactly like a bird at five in
the morning when you go back home
and then yelling it's like yo uh
it's five in the morning what are you so
happy about and that's
that was it it's nine in the morning
what are you young what happened that
you're yelling so much
i agree i agree what what at nine
girlfriend you got the energy
nah b so so yeah we just wanted to give
you guys these tips and we hope you guys
can use them but
uh but yeah at the end of the day guys
just just value yourselves
value value okay because it's low key
noble
that's gonna be the sentence for every
value value
[Music]
you